[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sectionnelles mais avant de le commencer
s'oublier pas les paroles genoux et
revient c'est évidemment tout ce qui a
permis à cette émission de 9 à cette
émission d'exister à cette vision d'être
encore là c'est à dire où il m'a fait
une chasse au trésor dans l'eure le
havre on vient du havre dans le haf dans
l'appartement lors il m'a fait aller
dans des endroits pas possible avait des
dégâts possible de votre appartement nom
de la ville a de la vie j'avais un
moquait déjà la vie n'est pas possible
elle même quoi ou plus ea non à la non
je suis pas contente
jour 3 vivre à wavre allasia pas
aujourd'hui ministre délégué chargé de
la citoyenneté a décidé de lancer à
partir de cette année un baromètre
annuel sur le harcèlement de rue tenter
d'endiguer le phénomène initiatives
qu'elle a résumé au journal 20 minutes
ce que l'on veut c'est créer des qsr des
quartiers sans relou alors harcèlement
est ce utile de mettre en place des
quartiers sont relou mais elle fait la
famille kardashian se retourne dans sa
tombe là
[Musique]
la promo de marlène schiappa quartier
son rôle ou la pointe d'humour de femmes
on parle pas que des règles en sept ans
non c'est pas également de samassa c'est
important de le dire
ouais avec les fait jouer absolue
c'était classe je crois que le message
est passé
voilà c'est vrai d'ailleurs je précise
que pardon c'est important mais songe de
moi même c'est vrai mais c'est vrai elle
même dans la rédaction elle utilise du
dissolvant te sent très mauvais à chaque
fois je lui signale à pauline ce n'est
pas possible de nous imposer ça je fais
ça le matin ça me détend en droit de
fermer autres bah c'est super bien fait
et qu'est ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur de
dents des streams et quoi des str inc
j'ai cru des strings or on me disait
c'est la première candidate qui m'offre
des strings elle a ce qu'il faut là où
il faut et subjugué par le mouvement des
fleurs
[Musique]
d'où vous trouvé ce nom i love my
popotin c'est une très bonne question
dont je ne sais même pas comment je les
trouvais mais ça fait déjà 10 ans
maintenant
alors essayez de vous rappeler il était
5 heures du matin vous sortez pas votre
cas vous cherchez votre voiture votre
copain vous dites qu un gilet au popotin
donc vous vous rappelez plus du tout
comme ans et plus non mais en fait je
sais que je l'écris parce que j'ai
beaucoup de copines qui se plaignait
tout le temps de leur popotin
moi je voulais évoquer l'anus une
chanson qui s'appelle zones la zone la
zone la zone érogène pour le coup qui
peut se lire d'ailleurs à double sens
bien évidemment il ya des endroits le
double salaire du miel raconte-nous
isabelle déjà comment vous avez pris la
chantier mais la zone moi je croyais que
c'était là le quartier là aussi
attention à double ses martyrs les
résultats du sondage c'est sûr penser
oui à 88% voilà non à 12% voyez la télé
est devenue trop coincé c'est vous qui
le dites
et ben voilà donc on va les jeunes je
trouve ça fou à nos constructions sont
si établi que souvent des hommes ne
parle pas de ma mère très facile mais
cette zone qui pourtant leur appartient
et two soutiennent comme une
civilisation de ce qu'ils sont alors que
ça leur appartient totalement et s'ils
veulent jouir de leur anus qu'ils
jouissent les cieux jouissent
[Musique]
tony sa règle et propose une soirée télé
tranquille en train de regarder star
wars
cet internaute a bien senti que son
animal de compagnie n'était pas si
rassurer surtout lorsque le méchant dark
vador apparaît
derrière le côté obscur du canapé le
chien a préféré se cacher la vidéo a
fait des millions de vues et même mark
hamill l'interprète de luke skywalker
n'a pu s'empêcher de voler au secours du
golden retriever chien intelligent
j'aurais tellement aimé pensé à me
cacher derrière le canapé lorsque je les
rencontrais pour la première fois
dans la voiture le petit caïd continue à
donner de la voix
j'ai appelé sa mère pour qu'elle vienne
vous chercher
soral d'accord voilà tu m'as être un bol
d'air dans ta tête
wallah tu rigoles un problème y en a
d'autres ouais et là actuellement c
ici tout le temps ouais enfin il voit
ici et là mal quantifiées parce que du
coup je suis tellement que je pense que
ça me brûle dans la nuque
ouais y'a toujours un trek avait été
fait avec le coeur je la mets tout le
coeur que tu veux si tu es un piètre
cuisinier ouais ça fera toujours de la
merde moi je m'en tape de côté du coeur
pour cuisiner conflentois sur la bouffe
et après tant qu en fait hormis ce que
tu veux je suis content je vais aller en
job donc et où vous mais avec elena donc
ça c'est hugh ça c'est cool
installez le potager sur le principe de
la supercherie t'en supplie de la
cuillère non mais il asperge aller
carrément cru que tu sais
parce que tarbes ont tout fait mais tant
qu avec un donc qui va enchaîner en une
minute 19 tirs réussis sur les 20 boules
qui sont installés devant lui cette
vidéo elle a fait un million et demi de
vue la première journée de sa diffusion
sur les réseaux alors derrière cet
exploit un jeune homme de 21 ans et qui
s'appelle tanguy penin lors du premier
confinement il a commencé à poster ce
genre de défi ça a explosé
et c'est devenu son métier il et
influenceurs pétant
mais ça se la pète en que sera olympique
a joué peut-être que ce sera aussi la
pétanque cristal eh bien vous savez quoi
pour avoir discuté avec lui hier je
pense qu'il peut y arriver c'est la
pétanque freestyle audio away extra en
vaut deux points
voilà tout plaquer devenir influenceurs
paix tant il était très vite avant
certains invités semblent encore prêts à
en découdre et superman n'arrive
toujours pas à calmer ses amis et
commencez pas lui aussi griser par un
apéro prolongée non j'ai pondu que ce
soit la fin